if you look at the current top ten in
the prime charts you'll see the top 10
largest primes at the moment and you may
notice that one of them stands out one
of them is not quite like the others
it's quite a special prime it was
actually discovered fairly recently was
discovered on October the 31st 2016 it
was discovered on Halloween 2016 but all
the other primes are Mersenne primes all
primes that are one less than a power of
two and there's a reason for that
because computationally it's quite easy
to check if they are primes or not right
there is a there is a test for that
which you can run quite quickly number
seven there is slightly different
there's a couple of reasons why it's
special and one of the reasons is that
it takes us one step closer to solving a
fifty-year-old conjecture so let's take
a look at this prime so this number it's
called up rough trying so tough Prime's
have this form where it's okay that's
some number multiplied by a power of two
plus one let's see if we can find a
troth Prime one gonna do as take her a
value I'm gonna say K is nineteen all
right let's take K as 19 and then we're
gonna multiply it by powers of two add
one and let's see we get a prime well
let's do the first power of two 19 times
238 plus 1 that equals 39 but that's not
a prime it's 3 times 13 that's no good
let's check for another let's try 19
again but let's do 2 squared so 19 s 2
times 4 well 19 times 2 is 38 so we can
double that again at 76 plus 1 that's 77
that's definitely not a prime that's 7
times 11 and let's keep going this
evening a fine pot let's do 19 times 2
to power 3 that is 153 153 is that prime
that's maybe not so obvious both know
that isn't fine
19 times 2 to the power 4 ok look into
keep looking I I think that is plus 1 of
course that is 305 that's definitely not
a prime okay another failure let's keep
looking for a prime let's do the
20 19 times two to the five plus one
I've got vas been 609 no that's
divisible by three it's gonna fit
actually we've got it we've got it look
at this one
19 times 2 to the power 6 1217 try that
is a prime finally we found 4 took a
while yeah it took a while but
eventually we found a prime in the 1960s
mathematician sierpinski said that if
you take something of this form it's K
times 2 to power n plus 1 and you keep
running for it there are numbers that
will never hit a prime so you'll keep
going forever and you'll never get it
probably in fact he said there were
infinitely many of them there's loads of
them out there the natural question is
what's the smallest one ah well we don't
quite know so they think it might be
this number 78550 7 as okay yeah that's
this case so I'm saying if we multiply
that by 2 to the N and then we add 1 and
we run through that process we'll never
hit a prime it's never going to happen
in fact I know that's never going to
happen so a mathematician called John
Selfridge showed that that's never gonna
happen he showed that this number
whatever it is
we'll always be divisible by one of
these 3 5 7 13 1937 or 73 so he said
he's always gonna be divisible by one of
those so it's never going to be a prime
that definitely is a co Pinsky number
okay this is a number that will never
hit a prime great but is it the smallest
one that we don't know now there's quite
a few candidates for this will in fact
we're gonna have to check all the
numbers smaller than 78550 7 well you
can do that and most of those were
eliminated until the roundabout
beginning of the 21st century there were
17 left 17 that hadn't been eliminated
so there might be numbers that are
smaller than 78550 7 and you could do
this and you'll never hit a prime so
there were 17 candidates left but thanks
to and
and computation that meant we could
start eliminating these candidates now
we started to eliminate them until there
were six left these are the six that
were left the smallest was ten thousand
two hundred and twenty three but here
are the others twenty one thousand one
hundred and eighty one twenty two
thousand six hundred and ninety nine
twenty four thousand seven hundred and
thirty seven fifty five thousand four
hundred and fifty nine and sixty seven
thousand six hundred and seven so there
were these six candidates left but
things started to slow down and I'm
afraid there was a gap of nine years
before we were able to eliminate one of
these six which was this one here ten
thousand two hundred twenty three
because we now know that forms a prime
here's here's our prime this is it there
it is we know it does former primes and
now this is struck after list leaving
five left now if we can eliminate those
last five candidates we will have proved
that 78550 seven is the smallest
sierpinski number so James was this
really large prime not so much found
because they were searching for large
primes but because they were trying to
eliminate case they that is part of the
motivation for this this was found for
by a guy in Hungary on his home computer
where it's downloaded a program you can
get it from the prime Grid website and
this program was designed to eliminate
those seventeen if I talked about and
using that program he finally eliminated
ten thousand two hundred and twenty
three so you can do this yourself using
your own home computer so he gets the
glory of solving that and the glory of
striking off one of these candidates off
our list so we have these candidates and
then you find a prime that kills it off
as a candidate so those Prime's are huge
this one that was found recently is over
nine million
it's long is that massive number the
largest of these primes that are killing
off candidates they've actually got a
special name the called Colbert primes
named after Stephen Colbert a Stephen
Colbert some people might know as the
host of The Late Show in America
American comedian I don't know why these
have been named after Stephen Colbert I
guess someone's a fan but if we can
eliminate all these candidates we will
have proven that 78550 7 is the smallest
sierpinski number we don't know it's
true it just feels true in our guts
it has truthiness obviously we love
these videos about arbitrary numbers and
obscure details but to see how
everything fits together to get that
bigger picture why not check out
brilliant
org here's just the start of their
number Theory course it's full of little
questions and puzzles that are not only
good fun but really help you get your
head around stuff and have a look at
that how can this not be quickening your
pulse rate whether you're really serious
about mathematics or you just love to
learn brilliance interactive sight is
going to teach you all sorts of amazing
stuff that you might not get from say
just a superficial video not that
there's anything wrong with videos of
course keep watching these too but
seriously I honestly think you'll enjoy
what these guys have made it's a really
really good resource it's also it's
really good fun to play with if you'd
like to check them out go to brilliant
org slash numberphile the first 314
people who do and sign up can get 20%
off the premium annual subscription
that's the first 314 see what we did
there they don't just cover mathematics
there's astronomy physics computer
science all sorts of good stuff thank
you to them for supporting this video
and I'll put some details in the video
description